Before we start today's episode, check this out. It's our brand new,
what if 100 books, it features the 100 most popular.
What if scenarios as suggested by you learn more and get this special
collector's piece by clicking in the link in the description below.
410.
Kilometers above the earth.
That's where the international space station floats.
Oh my goodness. I think are going to be sick.
What if you happen to be all the way up here,
but suddenly fell off and had to skydive down to earth.
What would happen
Is something like this possible?
How fast would you travel from this height and what would
happen once you got back to earth?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you skydive from the ISS,
the highest skydive in the world happened from 38 kilometers from earth.
The skydiver reached a speed of over 1300 kilometers per hour
and was in freefall for nearly four minutes and 20 seconds.
Our jump from the ISS would be 10 times as high as that
one.
What would happen once you jumped off?
Well, once you jumped off,
it wouldn't be a simple descent down to the ground.
That's because the ISS is moving at
27,600 kilometers per hour.
That's around 30 times, faster than a commercial airplane.
And if the ISS is moving at this speed, you would be too.
So instead of going straight down to the ground,
you'd be circling the earth while moving at this velocity,
you could potentially circle it for years before your velocity decreased enough
to descend down.
But since we only have a couple of minutes left in the video,
we're going to give you a jet pack with just enough fuel to stop the velocity.
Ah, much better, but.
Just because we've stopped you from going so fast,
doesn't mean this skydive would be any easier.
Thanks to Earth's gravitational pull you'd now be thrust towards the
planet surface instead of around it.
As you plummeted down to the earth surface,
you'd be moving at over 2000 kilometers per hour,
depending on your weight. And at this speed,
you would be experiencing over six G-forces during the
longest skydive ever.
The diver involved experienced four G-forces that's comparable
to a pretty intense
and fighter pilots experienced six G-forces when flying their jets.
But that takes a lot of practice and only happens or short periods
suddenly experiencing six G-forces with no prior practice
would feel like the most intense thrill ride of your life.
And this would only be the start of your speed.
As you move through the Earth's atmosphere,
your momentum would continue to increase.
You'd be moving so fast that you'd compress the air in front of you
causing it to heat up to temperatures as high as 1600 degrees.
As you continued heading toward earth,
you'd be experiencing more and more G-forces.
This would be like having eight times the amount of gravitational force you
typically experience on earth.
This kind of energy would likely cause you to lose consciousness.
Your blood vessels would burst and your organs would be shifting around
this pain would be incredibly excruciating.
But if you could hold out for just a bit longer,
your velocity would begin to slow down as the density of the air increased,
giving you more resistance.
If you somehow managed to wake up around this time at around
2,500 meters above sea level,
you could deploy a parachute and now you could enjoy the sights
as you come down to earth.
Just remember that once you land you'd need to get medical help immediately,
you'd likely have some internal bleeding and maybe some broken bones due to all
that gravitational pressure you've just experienced.
But what if you weren't lucky enough to have a parachute and fell
out of an airplane without one? Well,
that sounds like a story for another. What if.